now what did we establish this morning
we looked at how to do all that
differentiation for our universe trig
functions yeah oh sorry guys i forgot i
started now therefore this is a standard
setup for once you get your hair
background just the basic
differentiation and chamberlain tetra
how you could use it where are you going
to play ok now if you want you can turn
to question tell so you can follow along
with what I'm trying to get at it's a
series of show questions the case of
three show puns but you don't need to
read it for me to explain basically
what's going on here up here is a
picture on a wall ok so let me put it in
another cop r PR here's a picture
hanging up some distance raised on them
ok over there at E is some observer
that's you ok and you're looking at the
picture the question simply is where
we're headed is what is the best viewing
angle for the picture what's the best
doing it ok you think about this right
if you are right here like directly
beneath the picture you can't see the
picture that make sense like you're
looking up and like this squash w ok but
the further further you get away if you
get really really far away that angle
theta which is your viewing angle is
going to get smaller and smaller and
smaller is that they sense your super
super far away well just imagine the
picture is going to be very very tiny so
not a very good view you so therefore
right at the wall at the base of the
wall where the picture is what a good
view eagle really really far away that's
just getting worse and worse
progressively so somewhere in between
here there's a sweet spot ok have a
mathematician is therefore a sweet pops
what is a maximum ok so that's what
we're looking for right now here's part
a I have it on I'm just actually written
it up with this one thing that's missing
from it because it's not too much here
this is just get the geometry together
they want us to show this result here
that Peter is equal to that so
essentially they're trying to set up
I've got two quantities that are varying
in relation to each other right I've got
the viewing angle theta
and then I've got the distance away from
the wall from the base of the wall I
should take and that's X you can see X
you get bigger or smaller so what they
try to set up be that these two
quantities are related to each other
they want this as a function of this
right what will my angle be based on how
far away I am so that's all they're
trying to set up and you can see here
there's just some simple right angled
triangle trig involve you look at this
right angle triangle here at the bottom
in line 10 is opposite on adjacent like
so okay so you take tan inverse just to
get the angle by itself okay once you
combine that the result just kind of
slaps you in the face this is my
question I'm actually missing something
I think this answer would be fine but we
know a little better than this right
from line to line two and then I repeat
the exact same logic from like 32 line
four okay so therefore if I just focus
on the first one I'll be fine from all
that what to line two what have I done
to both sides what am I done I have
taken tan inverse of both science
correct so I've actually said something
sorry I've implied something that I have
not said right over there the right-hand
side sure enough tan inverse of three on
X is Teddy this periodic X but on the
left-hand side I've been something out
do you notice that actually should
really say this do you agree with that
okay now i just kind of artfully dodged
saying that it happens to be correct in
this case but the question is why why
can I just skip doing its we've seen
even just with taking square and taking
the square root you can't just assume
that an inverse our function and it's
inverse are just going to neatly cancel
each other out I can do this but the
question is why yeah
no restrictions on the day okay so
firstly tan inverse canna set any angle
in it right like when we thought about
my actions that we can accept any domain
right when we think about what tan
inverse looks like does it have to see a
problem that say leave us in close
inverse how he just kind of goes forever
okay however that's actually not the
problem that we're experiencing here
right that would be a thumbs up that
would be the thing we need to do is what
we were looking at was this this is one
of the first ones with that to remember
we with the sine sine inverse cos cos
inverse and tan tan inverse right do you
remember that they all look like X with
the exception of our domain shifted with
these sucking of this one which goes on
forever that's why your point solved
okay so it's true but it's actually not
relevant so this particular one yeah
right on and sorry the angle B is a cute
in this case and as a result it would
like because it within the domain very
good okay so you don't need to draw this
but I wonder how far you got with it
last time do you remember when I showed
you when we have scientists I diverse
cause of Kosovo's it's all nice and neat
but when you have the inverse on the
outside you're doing that one second you
do it this one first right do you
remember for sony of us or so away this
week guy do you have this you know that
guy right does anyone do they don't work
out what the cause oh cos inverse of
cause one look like yeah it's very
similar it's very similar but everything
is up right everything is between not
and pike do you remember what's the is
it this I think it's this pigs where is
no that isn't it is it that is it the
second one I drew someone check for me
is I don't know hooked on the head it's
funny autograph
is right yeah sure I think I think this
is what I'm getting I think this is real
okay now the reason we should expect
this is because you get the same y
equals x portion but you only get in the
domain you're supposed to be for cos
inverse that's not two pi okay and
that's why this is not to play as well
okay because that comes from the
registration Cosimo's now turns the
weirdest one I don't know if anyone did
tan inverse of tanner I'll show you what
it looks like it's win it looks like
this ok this is what tan inverse of 10
looks like and you can very very easily
verify this grab your calculator right
now if you don't if you haven't popped
it up on your desk or grinning and just
do something like say this is I'm
contending this is the tan inverse tan
graph right do take the immersive 1000 I
don't know say pie how about five what's
it going to tell you let's go to e0
because what's doing is this tan inverse
of 10 pi what Stan plane this is sine
pirate cause behind sine pi is 0 so this
is then tan inverse of zero and in the
range of tan inverse he's like are the
only angle that will do that for you is
zero so that's why it hands you that
dear does it hand you back pi which is
you put in it can see that zero so
that's why amer it up well now so
therefore looking see how I just slyly
substituted tan inverse tan of something
I just said yeah it's the sub thing
right I was contending tan inverse of 10
x equals x that's what i did i just
didn't make explicit but this is only
true in one small part of the domain
name lee from negative PI over 2 to PI
do more inclusive now here I'm okay I'm
out of the woods because being EP is not
just any angle BP is an angle in what
kind of triangle
it's in a running with trailer which
means the biggest it could possibly be
this angle here is a cute okay I ever
need to know that it's not enough to be
in a triangle if you've got an angle to
triangle like this say that's theta well
that's bep that's kind of a problem
right that's bigger than pylon to that's
over here that's outside the domain so I
need to know it's a right angled
triangle so really over here if you want
to be really correct if you're following
along with me really you should say i
can say that line because 0 is less than
BP which is less than apply on to ok
there is a restriction and it has to be
it's not increase in salaries either
because i actually have a triangle
straight line ok